ah
there you go
Mr Speaker I'd like to address the house
about how children feel about masks
remember I was going to say it's going
to use an expression we have to keep our
country gay but but it's not I mean for
some reason it's just not great anymore
do you frequently go to Hardee's is that
a common place you go okay that's pretty
funny David no it's not a joke when you
talk about the machines I just want to
clarify you mean electronic voting
machines and those because people write
to me and they say I'm worried Mike
pillow is gonna come after my espresso
machine my lathe my all these other type
I'm sure I'm sure they do David now
you're just being sarcastic and the
little left-wing humor I'm not I'm not
that could be your headline Mike Lindell
wants to get rid of the machine and
contrary to popular to belief
never been an escort for Senator Ted
Cruz but
to tonight it is the coolest thing I've
ever heard about Ted Cruz can satanic
possession be cured
well if you remove the possessor I guess
so yeah how is that done though well
biblically it would be through an
exorcism or something of that nature wow
that sounds extremely serious
well are you demonically possessed do
you agree with this book that is being
taught with kids that babies are racist
senator
not only do we have the DC jail which is
the DC Gulag but now we have Nancy
Pelosi's gazpacho police spying on
members of Congress they want to know
when you're eating they want to know if
you're eating a cheeseburger which is
very bad because Bill Gates wants you to
eat his fake meat that grows in a peach
tree dish and I'm going to show the
people what happened and you tell me
because let me see the video if you
don't mind uh this person with the hand
on your back
I gotta be honest it doesn't look that
bad but I I understand that looks gonna
be deceiving the decision of one man
to launch a wholly unjustified and
brutal invasion of Iraq I mean of
Ukraine
correct anyway uh
and congratulations on capturing an
audience motivated to spew so
consistently the corrosive and personal
vitriol that makes up the comments on
this video clip a likely Epitaph for you
eaten by his own children so he's really
really really not happy with me who's
the current president
well I don't believe that uh the current
president is a is a legitimate president
and we'll leave it at that is Joe Biden
currently the president even if you
think he's illegitimate is he the
president
I don't believe he is I don't believe
that is the current legitimate president
and what is the current legitimate
president
we have a current legitimate president
wow so in a sense there's no President
of the U.S right now um who's the
president of the United States right now
um Joe Biden is certainly the sitting
president but it looks like President
Trump likely won the election who's the
current president of the United States
chair
Joe Biden okay and is he do you think he
was elected legitimately
I think the election was stolen
personally who is currently the
president of the United States
Joe Biden okay and do you believe that
his presidency reflects the will of the
people as they voted in 2020.
uh I doubt it I I don't know I don't
know guys that's twenty dollars for coup
attain this doesn't include the tequila
I mean it's outrageous and we got Joe
Biden to thank for this and you know
what's so funny I am with minute police
officers so he pulled out a badge there
for those of you who couldn't see
excuse me Mr Walker please say a problem
I need to let you know Mr Walker you are
very well aware of the rules tonight yes
and you have a prop that is not allowed
sir I ask you to put that prop away well
it's not a problem this is real you see
Mitch McConnell stick out his hand and
then you see people just walk by you see
people walk by there is another there is
Gladys picnic she walks by and then they
just continue to walk by and Mitch
McConnell's standing there he's really
you know they say Joe Biden shook hands
with the air we have a president
representing our country as the most
important time in history who is
physically and mentally challenged let's
say there it is Trump at 71 Rhonda
sanctimonia said ten percent the FBI
executed a search warrant at Donald
Trump's home Mar-A-Lago we believe that
the
that by my colleagues today
throughout our year
warrants a criminal referral of former
president Donald J Trump John Eastman
and others for violations of this
statute David pakman a soy infused
triggered leftist I had to say about you
know what's funny is I don't really eat
soy I mean every once in a while I have
you know like mapo tofu but I where is
this soy thing coming from look at that
that is a freaking Predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you think
she's better than you and he's going to
beat you he thinks Pac-Man never talked
to the New World Order Pac-Man never got
tried to get hired by the kiss of your
group because Pac-Man's a loser is it
isn't this the absolute best